behind the scenes of friends tapings
there were some major misses that had
the live audience roaring for all the
wrong reasons as the cast fumbled with
their lines took occasional pot shots at
each other and simply could not stop
cackling about any of it
what do we smell
in the season 4 episode the one with
rachel's crush it's monica geller's
fresh baked cookies that entice all her
friends to come across the hall before
the scene could play out as fans
remember though there were a few takes
that didn't quite make it the cast and
crew had matt leblanc to thank for
bringing a bit of toilet humor to the
mix responding to lisa kudrow's line
what do i smell but the koi adlib
what do i smell
sorry
needless to say that wasn't in the
script this little ad-lib ended up
wasting a lot of time as leblanc and
co-star david schwimmer simply couldn't
get past his one-line fart joke to
finish out the scene what do i smell
the blood
eventually they managed to collect
themselves for long enough to make it
through the scene but it took a few
tries including one where they got so
close what do i smell
i don't know it smells good
ross didn't live with joey and chandler
for long but he wore out his welcome
pretty quickly thanks to that air
purifier his obnoxious hand gestures and
the many many boxes of stuff he left
scattered across their living room the
latter does prove to be a boon for the
boys in season 5's the one where ross
moves in once joey realizes he can build
a fort with ross's stuff so why don't
you be a grown-up and come watch some tv
in the fort in the closing scene
chandler comes home to find them playing
cowboys and indians in an innocent if
culturally insensitive moment
the blooper reel version though now that
was some racy stuff
what are you guys doing
awesome nothing
friends fans have often wondered why
ross saw so little of his son ben
throughout the series but perhaps this
blooper reel can shed some light on that
creative decision in the one where old
yeller dies ross is frustrated by how
many firsts he's been missing in the
boy's life and he wants to witness at
least one of those major milestones for
himself to that end ross tries to coax
the toddler into saying his very first
word during his visit as ross takes ben
to see rachel at the coffee shop he
tries to talk baby into saying dada to
no avail can you say dada
oh look i'm going to tell you mommy's
you said it anyway so you might as well
try no luck huh no
for a couple of takes however the tiny
actor portraying ben didn't quite stick
to the script you know you might as well
say it because i told you
the good news is that baby is growing up
to be sharp as attack the bad news is
it's the last thing the writers of this
episode wanted to happen your mommy's
just said it anyway so you might as well
try
huh
yeah he's saying that
who knew matthew perry had such a
penchant for crappy jokes there were
several instances on friends when
chandler would emerge from the bathroom
for one reason or another and as the
blooper reels reveal a lot of times the
actor went off script to make jokes
about what he was doing in there you
girls got a measuring tape
eventually courtney cox decided to play
along and the results were pretty great
while filming a scene for the one with
the nap partners in which monica
confronts chandler for breaking up with
a girl over her weight he was scripted
to be bothered by her knock at the
bathroom door instead he took another
approach
honey you gotta see this this is like
the size of my arm
cell phones have been ruining takes
since they could fit in people's pockets
but at least the results are often funny
during production on the one with joey's
new brain jennifer aniston got a
legitimate call on her cell phone while
she and lisa kudrow were filming a fight
about a different cell phone to quote
phoebe what are the chances
well somebody's actually here
hi let me call you right back i'm doing
a scene
that wasn't the only cellular mishap on
the series though aniston was also the
recipient of another unexpected dial-in
while taping her birthday scene on the
set of the one where they all turned 30
which just goes to show that she was as
widely reported very popular during her
time on the show better to be over the
hill
this gate comes with a phone
sometimes a blooper isn't an accident
sometimes it's a prank in the one with
the secret closet joey has to take a
pregnant rachel to the hospital after
she begins experiencing braxton hicks
contractions ross shows up late
complaining about the distance between
himself and his baby's mother to be
schwimmer had a hard time hitting his
cues for the scene though so matt
leblanc and jennifer aniston decided to
pull a prank on him after schwimmer
missed his mark and had to go back out
of frame to try again the two decided to
hide and let him walk into an empty room
just to see what he'd do
later when he forgot his line during a
take aniston playfully laid into him for
bringing the whole gang down and at the
the movie theater guys just suck
what happened here you used to be able
to act i know
remember joey's disastrous noodle soup
commercial audition with the kid who was
a more competent actor than him
um soup
i mean noodle soup i mean soup
well life imitated art in that regard
because cole sprouse who portrayed ben
in the later seasons of the show seemed
to be the only one who'd memorized the
script while shooting a scene with
jennifer aniston for the one with the
truth about london for example sprouse
confidently fed her the missing line
when she forgot what to say
now what is my first line
why did we agree okay
then when he shared the screen with
david schwimmer for a scene in the one
with the holiday armadillo sprouse had
to again remind his co-star of what to
say next
oh
chandler and monica's storyline in the
one where ross meets elizabeth's dad is
kind of a throwaway the two have a silly
misunderstanding over what time they're
supposed to meet up for a mini date and
their snafu becomes spotter for phoebe's
next book chapter their argument doesn't
make many friends fans lists of best
moments of course but perhaps it would
have if it had gone down the way it did
in the bloopers
we said we would meet at the coffee
house at six we said seven you dumb egg
of all the cast members who were paired
for two-person scenes throughout friends
lisa kudrow and david schwimmer had to
be among the most entertaining phoebe is
never afraid to call ross on his worst
decisions and since she seems to be the
one woman in his life who is neither a
relative nor an ex she's often his go-to
friend for unbiased advice the two also
get into a lot of weird situations
together including the time that they
each date half of a divorcing couple and
start bickering with each other in the
one with the engagement picture as their
arguments started to mimic the separated
couple david schwimmer and lisa kudrow
had a lot of trouble keeping it together
and finishing their scenes
and she uses sex as a weapon fine
things got so out of hand that schwimmer
suggested shooting the scene line by
line which kudrow seemed to game for
apparently it had worked out pretty well
for her before we'll just do the same
one line at a time
yeah one a legion i got an emmy
as friends joey and chandler definitely
find comfort in each other they're known
to hug so often that they eventually
have to ask themselves if it's getting
out of hand in the season 6 episode the
one with the mac and cheese during
shooting all of the repeated hugs and
back rubs started to get under their
skin
while we're here anything else
get off me
then things really went off the rails
when the mats decided to lean into the
discomfort of prolonged physical contact
what's that in your pocket
after so many seasons of bringing the
friends cast to life the actors started
to know their characters all too well
while filming a scene for the season 8
episode the one with the birthing video
david schwimmer realized midline just
how much of a dope his character was for
letting his pregnant ex-wife move in
with him while he had a new girlfriend
and neither he nor lisa kudrow could
stop laughing about it
i knew it i knew i wasn't crazy
for a while all the actor can seem to do
is sit there and think about ross's bad
decisions eventually kudrow has to ask
him if he's really so surprised all
right ready have you ever seen the show
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]